okay so good morning um today this
morning we are doing the bantine Empire
and I will be looking at three questions
the first question is why do we have the
bantin
Empire um historically we have
seen the Byzantine Empire as a
continuation of the Roman Empire we have
the bisan Empire because Constantine the
Great in 330
um transfer the capital of the Roman
Empire from Rome to banum which later
became which which he called New Rome
and which eventually was renamed to
constantinopole so why did he make that
transition okay that's the first
question second question
is how did the ban Empire rise it fell
it lasted
from um 3:30 until 1453 when the aroman
Turks
overran the uh capital of Constantinople
so it lasted for over a thousand years
arguably it is the most enduring World
Empire in human history so how was it so
successful that's that's the second
question and the third and last question
is why did It ultimately ultimately
decline why did it collapse what were
the factors Le that led to its eventual
demise okay so those are the three
questions we will we will be looking at
um this morning and what I want to do
first I want to present the scholarly
consensus what is generally accepted
what is generally believed about these
three questions and then I want to
present my own perspective um in order
to uh refute the scholar consensus all
right so let's start um this is the
Roman Empire in 117
and as you can see it is huge it it
spans across the
Mediterranean uh this is Spain over here
is
um
Anatolia Egypt the lant okay so it is a
huge World Empire and that's a problem
it's just much too big um unlike China
um it has no natural boundaries and
throughout most of its history history
it uh was invaded by barbarians what
what the Romans call barbarians
basically these Germanic Gothic tribes
from the north it also had a major
adversary in the Persian Empire uh at
this time they were fighting against the
parthians uh but later on they would
fight against what is what we call the
sassanian Persian
Empire um and so this was not a really
sustainable Empire internally as we
discussed last class there was a
contradiction they were an Empire but
they believed themselves to be Republic
it was important for them to maintain
Republican institutions like the Senate
even though um it was to the detriment
of the management of the Empire what I
mean by that is that throughout this
time on paper in Theory it was committee
it was ruled by committee okay the
Senate was really in command and as we
discussed in previous classes the Senate
is composed of the Roman aristocracy the
ruling houses of Rome when you have that
when you have committee uh rule by
committee um when Powers divide up
evenly among the ruling houses of an
Empire the only thing they can really
agree on is to be corrupt together and
and so the Senate was a huge problem
because they basically monopolized
wealth and there was a lot discontent in
the provinces there was a lot of
Disconnect among the people and the
Romans tried different solutions to
this um but none other Solutions
worked and in and eventually we had
something called the third Century
crisis the crisis of the third Century
which basically meant the Roman Empire
was about to disintegrate there were
civil wars going on uh there were these
invasions from the north uh there was
economic collapse there's a plague so in
the 3rd
Century um there it really seemed the
Roman Empire was on a brink of complete
implosion then a military genius by name
of uh de Clan he re reunit the Empire
and he recognized
we basically needed to change the system
and we needed to make radical changes in
order to save the Roman Empire
okay um as you can see it is extremely
difficult to protect Rome against um the
Barbarian Invaders over time eventually
the Western portion of the Empire will
be overrun by uh these barbarians who we
call the germanics the Goths the Slavs
the Hunts okay basically these are the
successors to the yamai people and they
come from the steps so they are
extremely
aggressive uh mobile people um who will
eventually overrun the Roman Empire and
they will
establish um basically the tribes that
will eventually give us the modern
states of
Germany um Britain France okay so
basically these are the ancestors of
Western Europeans all
right
um as um so as you can see
these um barbarians they will
established their own Empires and all
that we left after year about the year
500 is the Eastern Roman Empire which is
the
successor uh to the uh Roman Empire okay
and um even though they can call him
Romans and they identify themselves as
Romans historians refer to to the to the
Eastern Roman Empire as the byzantines
okay they they again they did they
themselves did not call themselves The
bantin byzantines it's what later
historians call them okay so the man who
makes this transition uh who basically
is a founder of the ban Empire his name
is Constantine the Great and what he
does that's very important is that he
shifts cap Capal from Rome to banum on
the
Bosphorus and today we call this place
conapo it's still there guys if you want
to visit it's called Istanbul in in in
turkey and it's a beautiful city uh
definitely one of the most beautiful
cities in the world now the question is
sorry uh I skipped the question then is
why was this move make and what modern
historians uh believe is that this was a
strategic
decision um first of all Rome was not
easily defended so it's very common
throughout its history for it to be
overrun by provincial military Governor
okay so think of Julius Caesar but also
there were others as well who did the
same thing who were extremely successful
in the provinces and they took the
military and conquered Rome it was very
easy to overrun Rome and then declare
himself uh Emperor so by moving into
Constantinople um he the city the
capital is now imprintable okay it is
impossible to besiege uh it is easily
defensible and how so I will show you
later on okay the other thing that's
really important about this transition
is conol is really at the center of the
Empire now Rome was too far to the west
and most of um the Roman her's most
wealthy provinces the most important
Province like Egypt Anatolia and the
lavant were actually in the East okay so
it's recognition the fact the center of
gravity um in the empire was really in
the East and the third reason is again
throughout most of its history Rome's
main competitor were the Persian Empire
to the East and so by moving to Conant
pole it allows the emperor to most
easily and most directly respond to the
threat of the Persians okay so this is
the scholarly consensus okay um but as I
will show you later on I disagree with
this consensus I think there was a much
more important reason why Constantine
made this move okay
um the ban Empire becomes this the um
birth place of modern Christianity okay
Constantine the Great is the first
Christian Roman Empire Emperor he
converts to Christianity but not only
that but he lays the intellectual basis
for Mar Christianity for something call
the Council of Nikia niia the
pronunciation is different okay it's
properly pronounced Nikia but most
people pronounce it NAA okay so the
Council of NAA we talked about this last
semester where the Council of NAA was
established to answer uh a theological
debate in the Christian world what is
the nature of Jesus what is relationship
with God as we discussed uh one more
popular interpretations explanations is
the idea of arianism where Jesus is a
less Divinity to God the Council of
nessia Nakia established the idea of the
Holy Trinity which is that God Jesus and
holy spirit are are co-equal they are
separate but they are co-equal we call
this the Holy Trinity the godhead okay
so that is conant's major
contribution um after Constantine one of
his successors
theodosius makes Christianity the
official religion of the Roman Empire
there's now a Crackdown on both the idea
of paganism which used to be the
religion of the Roman Empire as well as
the ideaa of heresy okay especially the
idea of
irism um he also built something called
the FI Doan walls which makes Conant
basically impenetrable okay it makes it
a impenetrable Fortress and allows it U
Conant to stand for a thousand years
okay as you can see from the F fi Doan
walls um it's huge okay this is just a
person you can see that there are two
walls there's a m protecting it um so
for about a thousand years these walls
protected the city there were that many
soldiers from the city you didn't
actually need that many soldiers to
protect against
Invaders the other thing so uh these
walls are still standing today you can
actually go get on a plane fly to
Istanbul and visit these walls okay they
were they were basically designed to
stand for all eternity and that was the
idea of constantinopole the Eternal City
okay um they also had seaw walls so not
only could you not attack conable from
by land you couldn't even attack it by
sea one of the Great
Inventions um of constant pole is the
idea of Greek Fire okay the story is
that um they were being attacked by the
Muslims this is in the 8th century when
uh the Muslims are expanding throughout
the world they're conquering uh both the
Sass sassanian Empire as well as the uh
Roman Empire and they want to obviously
overrun kopol and and ultimately what
saves the city is the invention of some
called quick fire which is basically
kerosene right you take kerosene you
throw it at someone and then the boat um
is light on fire and the story is that
this was invented by a heniz Jew who
converted ity and he he has this great
idea and then he approaches the emperor
with this uh invention and the emperor
believes that he is an angel sent by God
to save the city okay and so it is
impossible to actually launch a naval
Expedition against cono because they'll
just burn down your
ships
okay um at the height of the bintine
Empire it almost reestablish lishes
reconstitutes the entire Roman uh Empire
and this is the year 565 at this point
the emperor is Justinian and at this
point the one who is leading the
military of the byzantines his name is
bis serus and he's considered the last
great Roman general okay his military
genius is on par with that of Julius
Caesar Hannibal all the great generals
and through his military conquest but
the bising Empire ex um is able to
expand its influence but as we learned
in this class once you reach a peak of
Empire there are problems okay so the
first problem is that your city becomes
overpopulated and when your city becomes
overpopulated it becomes suceptible to
the plague okay so there's something
called the justan plagu which wiped out
anywhere between 50 to 60% of the entire
population of Constantinople
at this point uh the popul population of
the city is about 500,000 half a million
the plague killed 300,000 people that's
a lot of people okay even today Scholars
debate where this plague came from or
originally we belied it came from grain
ships from Egypt right because conol
Imports all its food from Egypt and so
there were Rats on these ships and these
rats spread basically the bonic plague
now historians believe that actually
came from the steps the Hunts and
through their Invasion okay so we don't
know what happened we just know uh we
just know it killed a lot of people and
this greatly uh reduced the power of uh
the Empire also when you have these mil
military conquests you
overextended okay so it is very
difficult to maintain this Empire and
the third problem is that that whenever
there's a military expansion the Empire
the emperor comes in conflict with the
general so even those Justinian and
milit serious they were great friends
their wives were great friends they
themselves had a lot of personal
conflict in fact um towards the end of
his life bis Serius was actually tried
for treason and there were many times
when bis serus was on military campaign
it was clear that Justinian was trying
to sabotage him because obviously if
your Emperor you're afraid that uh your
general your great conquering General
will eventually come back and take your
throne okay so because of what happened
between Justin and Blas basically this
was the last time that the bines uh
embarked on a massive military
campaign okay from now on they're
defensive and also they focus on the
idea of diplomacy basically bribing
their enemies not to attack them
especially the Hunts uh but also the
Arabs as well as the Persian Empire
okay this is the Hagia Sophia the
cathedral to wisdom and this is the
great Monument uh the great legacy of
the Byzantine Empire it's it's
absolutely beautiful again guys this is
this what's amazing it's still there
okay you can actually get on a plane go
to istano and visit this place it's
actually it's absolutely gorgeous um
definitely worth
visiting all right now why did constant
constant pole
fall um and so what happened was that
again even though conle itself is
impenetrable it's
Invincible um it's still it's still an
Empire and So eventually its regions
were eventually overrun by great enemies
so for example in about the year 1450
and this is 3 years before the eventual
fall of the of the city uh the otoman
Empire just it's basically toen taken
over the byzantines okay and the only
city left standing is constant pole okay
so you can see over here are the
Ottomans over here is the Ottomans
okay the Ottomans were able to conquer
the city because of the invention of
Siege engines okay these are these
cannons are as big big as houses and
they basically overwhelm the walls and
allow the Ottomans to overrun the city
now what's important to understand is
even though the bisan tees were
Christian and the Ottomans were Muslim
and even though uh the Turks overran the
city the Turks were extremely respectful
to the citizens of the city because they
were considered the hearers the
successors to the Roman Empire uh and
this was the center of what we call the
Orthodox church so the so so the
citizens were treated extremely well
okay um this again is another picture of
the siege of constant all right let's
talk lastly
about um the significance and power of
the city the city was the center of the
world for hundreds of years but both
intellectually because it again it was
the here to not just the Roman Empire
but also to Greek
civilization um it was also in terms of
trade the capital of the world because
it was a meaning place of both the agian
which leads to the Mediterranean as well
as the Black Sea which leads into um
what is Russia Today okay so if you
wanted to go anywhere you basically had
to go through Conant it was really a
center of the world and through trade
taxing trade the city became extremely
wealthy also because it was a center of
the world it was very Multicultural very
Cosmopolitan you had basically all major
ethnicities living inside the city Jews
Christians Muslims were all treated with
extreme
tolerance they basically had their own
quarters within the city okay as you can
see at its height the city was was
extremely
beautiful and very wealthy it was really
for 100 years the capital of the world
the capital of the universe
basically um as you can see it is almost
impossible to besiege okay you you can
never cut it off from supplies you can
never isolate the city because it is the
meeting place of so many rivers okay
this is the
bosor okay so that is the Roman Empire
okay um so this is the again what we
know about it and now I'm going to
explain um my theory to these three
questions why did Constantine make the
move from Rome to bizantium why did it
rise why did it de climb okay but before
I start uh with my explanation are there
any questions about what I just
presented this is all pretty basic stuff
this is stuff you can find on the
internet uh um on Wikipedia you can ask
chat GB I'll probably give you the same
answers okay but are there any questions
so far about uh con Paul in the B Empire
before I I I I present my
ideas was this clear to you
guys any any questions
guys maybe this is something you're
coming up to it is like shoot the
question down but uh I I remember
reading like in the early years of the
the Roman
Empire know Augustus
Tiberius so on Le culture there was GRE
and like the
emperor
writing Greek and all that kind of stuff
and
so like I I know move to Conant was a
couple hundred years after but was there
a certain cultural pull at the time were
certain Roman Elites feeling like they
need to be closer to like the core
culture right okay that's a great
question so culturally were the Romans
at this time Greek or Roman um and
you're actually right duck in that Greek
culture it's really the Hedon right I
mean it's so many so much so Superior to
Roman culture I mean Romans really were
peasants uh who built an Empire but the
Greeks uh basically built Western
Civilization okay you had Homer you had
Plato you had Herodotus the the Romans
were aware of this and this was a
conflict within Roman culture
civilization for a long long time
because they felt that even though they
had conquered the world they were about
to be C conquered culturally by the
Greeks so the Romans were aware of this
and they rebelled against this and um
you weren't here for my lecture on the
inad but really uh austa Caesar
sponsored the writing of the indiat in
response to the hemony of of Greek
culture so even though you're right in
that most of the Roman aristocracy they
Embrace Greek culture uh such as like
Mark Anthony right uh Mark Anthony saw
himself as more Greek than than than
Roman um there was a lot of push back
from the empire against this okay so um
but eventually as we'll see eventually
Greek culture does triumph all right so
so so let me explain how all right so
the first question I want to look at is
why did Constantine make the move
from um Rome to Byzantium okay so let me
give you some
background so um during the time of
Augustus
Augustus we we we today see him as the
first Roman Emperor but we he do himself
see himself as the first emperor he just
saw himself as just a citizen of Rome
okay he he is what we call a prin or he
call himself a PRP and this is where we
get the um Modern English word Prince as
well as principal High School principal
and it just means first first citizen so
again the problem with Rome is that you
had the aristocracy uh through the
Senate monopolize all wealth and power
and this led to a lot of contradictions
and conflicts within the Roman Empire
and so the
solution that Augustus proposed is make
the prinet make me the CEO okay this
it's still committee it's still rule by
committee but I'll be the coordinator
I'll be the CEO okay and the idea here
was even though this was not a great
system it did preserve the culture
okay the history the Legacy uh and the
traditions of the Roman people and that
was what was important to protect and
preserve the uh culture especially the
idea of libertas okay
Liberty um but this system didn't really
work right you had these Civil Wars you
had a lot of provincial um riots um
Rebellion so so this system simply
didn't work and this led to what we call
the crisis of the 3rd century when
basically the Roman Empire was about to
collapse okay and again as we said a a a
governor a a commander named dark Clan
he saved the Roman Empire by reuniting
okay and at this point he's like this
system doesn't work what we need to do
is study the Persian Empire because even
though we don't like the Persians their
their empire seems a lot more
sustainable and continuous than our
Empire okay and so this started a period
what what we call the dominant okay
basically the idea of starting an
imperial bureaucracy centralizing power
uh with the emperor through the
bureaucracy and the Romans hated this
idea okay what what what emper
discovered is this cultural
shift um what the Romans just found AB
disgusting go back to the Assassin jul
assassination of Julius Caesar
right the the Romans are extremely
culturally arrogant why did they
assassinate Julius Caesar and the people
who assassinate Julius Caesar were his
best friends in fact we believe Marcus
Brutus who was one of the lead
conspirators was actually his biological
son right why because Julius Caesar was
threatening the cultural traditions of
Rome they were afraid that Julius Caesar
would become king so what these Emperors
uh first under Diocesan but especially
under Constantine discovered is it's
really hard to change culture and
there's really one solution to this
problem okay to understand this let's
let's run a thought experiment okay okay
so you understand the percentage of
culture okay so we're at at at school
and this school is known for being
Innovative it's being it's known for
being student centered it focus a lot on
activities and extra curriculum right
and that's great I'm very supportive of
this but let's just
say that uh the school brings me in as a
consultant and ask me to help improve
the school and I do lot I spend months
interviewing students and teachers I I
feel this school is great in terms of
innovation but it needs to focus more on
academics kids need to read more kids
need to focus more on um test scor
and then you have a perfect balance okay
and that's my solution well I'm pretty
sure if I tried that um I'd be fired
within a week okay and the reason why is
I am attacking your cultural Traditions
I'm attacking your identity your sense
of self so if I want to implement my
vision I can't force my vision on you
the only thing I can really do is switch
schools and build my own school okay
does that make sense you guys okay and
this is this is uh a pretty persistent
uh thing throughout the world okay so
that's why
Constantine made the move to Byzantium
he recognized that if I'm going to build
an Empire and Rome needs to be an Empire
if it is to
endure I need to switch cultures and the
best way to switch culture is by moving
your capital from Rome to
Byzantium and when he did that
the entire culture shifted okay so so
let me very quickly explain the cultural
shift in
Rome it was
Pagan okay oh by the way um Pagan is not
the word that they use okay Pagan is a
word that Christians use to insult them
basically okay but but but for the sake
of comedians we'll use the word Pagan uh
that was the religion they were Roman
meaning that they had a distinct
cultural
identity and lastly they were Republic
meaning they were run by the Senate
basically okay not just Senate but by
tradition and uh by custom
okay by conole okay the basan empire was
completely different first of all it was
Christian and the Pagan and Christian
world view are in conflict with each
other this is a major shift second is
they were
Multicultural so as duck says um in the
time of Rome time of Augustus there was
a major conflict major debate uh between
Roman culture and Greek culture but when
they switch switch over to conop pole
they completely Embrace Greek
culture in fact the language switched
from being Roman to Greek they spoke
Greek and they embrac Greek culture
Herodotus Plato uh were
major thinkers that the that the um
basan Empire embraced and
celebrated and lastly it switched for me
Republic meaning that it went uh being
run by Senate to an
Empire which basically meant it was
being run by a
bureaucracy okay so bantine the bis
Empire is a very distinct enti from the
Roman Empire historians today argue the
basian Empire is
continuation of the ran Empire but
that's only a superficial and shallow
understanding culturally the basian
empire was a radical departure from the
Roman Empire or the Roman Republic okay
and so I will explain what these
differences are and the and this it's be
important because it's going to inform
for our understanding of future events
in western civilization okay so let me
first explain the difference in
worldview between the Pagan and the
Christian all
right all right
Pagan and again guys I will have to make
a lot of
generalizations but it's a useful
framework for the understanding of um
ancient cultures okay so so what's the
Pagan worldview well in the Pagan
worldview there are different lers to
your understanding of the world the
forces the supernatural forces that you
interact with intimately are the
gods okay and the gods is really a
metaphorical way to understand
nature right so um in nature there are
all these natural forces that we can't
really see for example the wind we can't
really see the wind but also we can't
really see creativity or luck well in
the Pagan worldview these hidden
invisible forces are rendered and
expressed as
Gods okay and the gods are those that we
interact with every day on an intimate
basis was very important for us to
maintain good relations with the gods by
making ritual tributes to the gods okay
so sacrifice and rituals were very
important part of the Pagan worldview
above the Gods are actually even higher
invisible
forces that no one has control of okay
which this which includes fate which
includes luck okay Fortune okay but
there all there all but there are these
invisible forces that even the gods must
submit to and then at the highest level
are what are called um
Unwritten and immutable immutable just
means unable to change Eternal laws of
the universe and think of this structure
as giving the universe some order and
structure okay so think of
gravity right it's it's an Unwritten and
IM inal law of the universe and what
they really mean by this is the idea
really of karma or Justice right if you
do good in the world good will happen to
you if you do evil in the world evil
will happen to to you it may not happen
to you but it may happen to your
children okay so there is a cosmic
balance to the world and this is really
the Pagan worldview
right the Christian worldview is very
simple there's you okay you and then
there's God and the thing that matters
is your personal relationship with God
that's it guys all right so let's look
at the three major differ differences
between the Pagan worldview and the
Christian worldview okay and again this
is a generalized simplified version and
we use it in order um to be clear about
the differences and that there are in
fact differences all right so the three
major differences are this the Christian
worldview introduces into uh the Roman
world three ideas that really didn't
exist before okay they are
truth evil
and the
individual now these ideas actually
existed in other Traditions like the
Jewish tradition and the Persian
tradition through Zionism but they
really didn't exist in the Greek and the
Roman
tradition so the counterpart to truth in
the Pagan tradition is the idea of um
chaos or
luck okay so there's no structure to the
universe in the Christian worldview
there's a God who has designed the
universe and that is the
truth okay so the intention of God is
the truth the plan is the truth whereas
in the Pagan worldview there's no design
guys it's just complete random chaos and
you just have to do try your best in
this world okay in the Christian
worldview is the idea of evil which is
if you go against the intention of God
if you commit sin that is evil
now what's interesting for us is in the
Pagan worldview the opposite idea is
action okay in other words in a word of
chaos you have to act you have to do
stuff if you refuse to act you are a
slave so think back to the ilad right in
in the ilad Achilles says why he is in
Troy while he's fighting in Troy and he
says that before he came to
Troy he was told his fate he could
either
die
old back at home or he could die young
in
Troy but by dying young in Troy he'll
become famous he'll be remember forever
and for Achilles that's not really a
choice what he's being told is you must
come to Troy and you
must die and that will win you eternal
glory okay it's the idea of action also
think of the Romans okay in their
Legends they have they have a name Nam
musas remember at the beginning of the
Roman
Republic the Romans are besieged by the
atrian king and mushas is a young normal
man only 20 years old he decides to
assassinate the king in order to free
the Romans he swims across the Tyber and
he's about to do his deed but it's
payday and the king is with his
secretary and they look alike they dress
alike they look alike and Muses is
hiding with his dagger and he knows it's
5050 okay now for us we'd be like you
know what 50/50 is terrible odds so let
me come back another day or let me be
more patient but for muus it's fortune
favors the Bold so he's like 50 is great
it's great odds I'm never getting better
odds so he takes his he takes his um dag
and he kills the secretary okay he
misses then he's captured by The King
The King wants to torture him and force
him to confess and the King threats him
and says I will burn you alive okay
there's a great fire beside musas if you
do not tell me the truth and what musas
does is he puts his hand Into the Fire
and lets it burn in front of the king
and that scares the king okay that's the
idea of action you make your fortune for
your
action you cannot sit and wait you
cannot deliberate you cannot be clever
you just act you're just Brave okay
that's a pagan worldview this is
important for us because the um people
who will in feature in our course who's
very important and who follows worldview
are also the Vikings okay so the Vikings
she the similar worldview it's a pagan
worldview the last thing is the idea in
the Christian worldview it's an
individual that matters the individual
individual soul is what
matters okay but in the Pagan worldview
what matters is the
community why are
Achilles why is Achilles funny in Troy
why is muus sacrificing himself for Rome
because they want to remember by their
Community all right so let me give you
two examples of this let's go back to to
the ilad hector remember Hector Hector
in Iliad he is the greatest Trojan
Warrior and he's destroying the Greeks
because Achilles refuses to
fight but then Achilles um enters the
battlefield and at this point Hector's
Lieutenant tells him Hector Achilles is
back let's go home let's go hide behind
the walls of Troy will be fine but
Hector says no fortune favors to bold
the gods are with me and so of course
Achilles and the Greeks destroy the
Trojans and they all have to and they're
all forced to run back to the walls of
Troy every Roman enters Troy except for
Hector Hector stays outside the walls of
Troy and waits for Achilles to come he
knows for a fact that Achilles will kill
him Achilles is a God
he's a great warrior but he's not a
God and at this point he knows he's
about to to be killed and most of us
would just sneak back into the walls of
Troy right he can't do that because he's
afraid of being um laughed at by his
Lieutenant he's afraid of Shame he has
to die for his community okay so that's
Hector but also think about
luria
Lua lucrecia remember is the woman Noble
woman who is raped by uh the son of uh
tanius Superbus the last king of Rome
and this is what starts the uh Rebellion
that uh overthrow the Roman
monarchy lucrecia is raped and then she
kills
herself because she's Dishonored and
Augustine remember Augustine city of God
he writes about this okay and from his
perspective it was a crime for Lucretia
to kill herself why because we are all
the creation of God therefore we are the
property of God therefore when we cure
our when we kill ourselves we're
committing um a sin against God we are
basically stealing from God and that's
why if you commit suicide you'll be
condemned
to Hell forever okay you'll be condemned
to to damnation forever and then Austin
explains lucrecia killed herself because
she's afraid of the shame that she would
have to endure if she lived she was she
was afraid that she' be laughed at by
The Other Woman of of Rome okay and
that's the idea of community versus the
individual all right
okay so um this so it's a radically
different worldview the Pagan versus the
Christian let me explain some other
differences for example the attitude
towards
sex okay Christians because we live in a
Christian world we know that sex is bad
okay sex should only happen between
husband and wife and it should only
happen for the purpose of
procreation we shouldn't do it because
we enjoy it the pagans had the complete
opposite attitude towards sex sex was to
be embraced it was to be enjoyed it was
to be
celebrated why because if it if the gods
didn't mean for us to have sex they
wouldn't make it so much fun okay so sex
was a very important part of pagan uh
life as well as violence okay they also
embraced and celebrated violence so
think about the Vikings think about the
Romans right they love violence and the
Christians hated
violence
so the argument is that the Christian
worldview is an improvement on the Pagan
worldview because the pagans they had
things like orgies they had things like
child sacrifice they had things like
genocide okay this is all bad
right but remember and this is really
important okay these are just two
different worldviews and it's hard for
us to objectively assess which one is
better we can only say that they both
have their benefits and they both have
their uh
consequences okay an example is food if
if we were to go to America today and
look at the food that Americans eat we
be discussed right hamburgers Coca-Cola
french fries but guess what guys if if
Americans were to come to China they
would be equally disgusted by the food
that Chinese eat okay like malatang and
and this stuff okay some of this stuff
is really bad for you so I would keep
that in mind um it's easy for us to be
culturally arrogant and say like we are
so better than these
ancients but um it's all a matter of
perspective if we were to go back in
time and look at the Pagan World we'd be
disgusted by the murderers by by the
Violence by all the sex going on okay
but at the same time and this is really
hard for us to understand but if they
were to come here there the time travel
and come here and see our world they'd
be disgusted okay because like from
their perspective we behave like
slaves Achilles is out winning glory on
the beaches of Troy while we are in
school memorizing usess facts so that we
can get usess piece of Pap pieces of
paper so that we can make useless pieces
of money right of money is paper they
would not understand why we're doing
this to ourselves right so I would keep
that in mind like the Pagan worldview is
very different from the Christian
worldview and that's it all right and in
fact we will later in the semester
discover that there are some thinkers
such as nii Frederick nii who
believe that the switch from the Pagan
worldview to the Christian worldview was
a major setback M of civilization
okay all right any questions about the
difference between the pagans and
Christians before I move
on any
questions was this clear all right now
let's move on to the idea of republic
versus
Empire okay and look I mean um the
differences are pretty St AR right so in
a republic it's
usually um there's there's like
egalitarianism okay everyone's opinion
does
matter and in an
Empire there's a hierarchy okay so
that's the first major difference okay
in a republic people are
egalitarian and in an Empire there's a
hierarchy so think think about this in
the Persian Empire
um if you were to meet the emperor what
you have to do would what you have to do
was prostrate yourself first and then
kiss his
feet all right that's the idea of Empire
but in the Republic you didn't do that
in fact even though uh Rome was becoming
a welfare City a major tradition in Rome
was you didn't lock your doors you
didn't have guards so a senator who was
in charge of go he was literally uh he
could literally put millions of people
to death if he wanted to he didn't lock
his door so you the lonliest Roman could
just walk into his house and have tea
with him or coffee with him and talk
about um life okay that was the
tradition in Rome other also another
thing is when Roman Senators walked the
streets of Rome they always carried an
umbrella something called a
um um yeah to protect themselves Okay
the reason why is this um Roman houses
were two
stories and they didn't have switch
system so if you need to go to the
bathroom you did so using a bucket on
the second floor okay and so what
happened is if you saw someone you
didn't like walk the streets you would
actually take your bucket and throw all
this at him okay that's literally
what they did so if you're a senator um
you could be the most powerful man in
the world but you could still literally
risk having thrown at you okay so
that's the Roman world it was
egalitarian where's an Empire there's
hierarchy so in the galarian world it
means there's openness people are open
to new ideas there's debate okay
literally anyone could propose a new
idea whereas in the uh
Empire um it was very close system okay
they didn't like new ideas so go back to
the example of Greek fire right a guy
and it's a story so we don't know if
it's true but a guy had to go to the
emperor and get his approval before the
military could adopt it that's really
inefficient guys okay the Greeks would
have just gone and done it the Romans
would have would have let the commanders
make their own decisions it would not
happen the decision of the Senate it
would have been the decision of the
military commander that that was
appointed by the Senate okay so um the
the Republic would be much more
Innovative than the Empire because the
Republic would be much more open okay so
um there' be a lot more
diversity in a republic
and in an Empire things would be much
more
conformist okay you be you would have a
lot more creativity a lot more diversity
within a republic than Within an
Empire right and that's kind of
intuitive because if you think about it
an Empire has so much more people and so
much more wealth and resources than a
republic but at but historically we
found that republics and democracies are
much more Innovative and creative than
Empires the reason has to do with the
idea of a bureaucracy right something
that a democracy or
a republic does not have his idea of an
imperial
bureaucracy all right they have
bureaucracies but they're not that big
and they're not Imperial so let's talk
about
bureaucracy right and this is a very
important idea that I want you guys to
remember for the rest of semester
because we will refer to this idea right
now in the beginning bres are good for
Empires because because what they do is
they do centralization
all right they're able
to centralize the Empire unite the
Empire basically second thing that they
do that's important is the idea of
systemization all right basically keep
records uh create laws systemization and
last is the idea of calization
standardization uniformity
okay so getting people speak the same
language getting people to use the magic
system um getting people to use money
all right and this creates tremendous
wealth within the empire in the early
years because again what you have is you
have the creation of
money because you have a legal
system and you have a
monopoly on
violence monopo mind just means that
these neighbors don't fight anymore okay
because a police there are these courts
they can just Sue each other there's a
legal system and people are now using
money um this leads to contracts and
this leads to trade and increased
economic
activity so you have peace and
prosperity people feel safe uh people
feel that life is predictable so they do
more they work harder okay and this
leads to in the early stages of Empire
to
tremendous
Prosperity okay
but over time what will happen is this
bureaucracy will
aify meaning the people in within the
bureaucracy will think of how to use the
bureaucracy for their own personal
benefit okay we we we can say this is
corruption okay so centralization leads
to corruption where just a minority
people with all the power use it for
their own personal benefit they're
basically parasites the the technical
word we use for this is rent seeking
okay rent seeking so think of
landlords who charge rent to their
tenants well if it's a monopoly they can
charge as much as they want there's
nothing you can do about it okay it's
what we call R seeking So centralization
eventually leads to
corruption systemization leads to
ultimately
stagnation okay there's nothing new
um going on and calization leads to the
idea of Conformity or H homogenization
okay where everything becomes the same
where everything's this where everything
is
Bland
right does that make sense all
right okay so why this happens
is because even though the bureaucracy
is only an institution among different
institutions okay so think about this
you have the Imperial
bureaucracy but they are compenent
against the court system okay which is
basically Emperor okay and the court is
usually controlled by Unix okay so these
are Servants of the emperor the
burocracy is up against the court it's
also up against the nobility right the
traditional power of society it's also
up against the military
it's also up against the
church okay so there are
different um institutions that can
counter the bureaucracy but over time in
terms of peace and prosperity if things
are really stable eventually the
bureaucracy triumphs over all these
other
institutions okay and the reason why is
this first is the y can
monopolize
status okay and
Mobility so if you're just an ordinary
person well the best way to rise from
our society is for the bureaucracy this
is certainly true in China right where
every wants to be bureaucrat because
that's seen as the mechanism of
achieving social status as well as
social
Mobility
also proces
monopolize
information it controls what information
flows into the system it controls what
the emperor sees okay so we so we can
say this is about
censorship and
sequency and the last thing that it does
is monopolizes the idea of
narrative okay it it controls the
production of
culture and we
can uh so and it does this mainly
through the process of writing history
okay so remember history is the creation
of a cultural narrative to bind people
together and it's usually the Imperial
bureaucrats who do this in other words
what's important for us to understand is
the bureaucrats have a
monopoly of
literacy and
knowledge they control the schools they
control the media they control history
writing they control how you think and
um
write so even though these are they are
competing institutions the bureaucracy
by controlling this meta reality that's
culture it controls the way like these
um other
institutions behave okay so um the
example I want to use is the idea of the
godhead all right the
godhead so my argument to you is the
godhead it's really a bureaucratic
invention right because remember um in
during the C of NAIA NE neia there's a
debate as to the nature of Jesus there
are these arens who believe that Jesus
was a lesser Divinity then there were
people called uh who believed in
modalism who who just believed the Holy
Spirit Jesus and God were diff were
different forms of the same entity then
you have partialism which is say that
they are a part of the same entity okay
and these three different explanations
make sense make they make intuitive
sense the idea of the godhead where God
Jesus and the Holy
Spirit are coequal separate but the same
thing makes no
sense and the reason why they would do
this is to create a sense of
mystery right and distance
and
secrecy and that my friends is a
definition of a
bureaucracy
right I'm not sure if you de
bureaucracies I have they suck they
dehumanize you so think
of I'll just use a silly example right
so in America there's there's something
called a census and on the census you
have to write down what racial group you
belong to and the racial group racial
group I belong to if American is
Asian-American right guess what guess
who else belongs in that group Indian
people Vietnamese people Japanese people
Korean people that makes no sense we
know that in in uh Asia the Indian
culture is vastly different from the
Japanese culture which is vastly
different from the Korean culture and
the Chinese culture and the vietamese
culture okay these are different people
with their
own uh belief systems but in a
bureaucracy it just categorizes everyone
together almost randomly or
indifferently okay and that's why I I
would make the argument that ultimately
Multicultural societies are not as
creative as as tribal
societies okay tribal versus
Multicultural think about the
Multicultural societies that are are
around us today okay sing Singapore is a
Multicultural Society Canada is a
Multicultural Society they're not very
creative guys they're very Bland they're
very
conformist they're very
bureaucratic
okay very tribal societies like the
Greeks the Greeks were extremely tribal
they were extremely s sistic they were
extremely
creative right as
were um um as are the Europeans
okay as are the
Vikings and the reason why is
tribalism is energetic it makes you
passionate it makes you think deeply
about the
world whereas in in a Multicultural
Society
people have to spend their energies
getting along with with with each other
it's important not to be offensive okay
and so it's because of these three uh
reasons the certain the certain cultural
construct of the banan Empire uh it was
Christian it was
Multicultural the word we can also use
we can also use is Cosmopolitan okay um
also it was bureaucratic the bisan tees
were not a very creative
people okay even though they had access
to every culture in the world even
though they had access to the classics
like Plato Homer Herodotus as well as
Virgil they were not that creative in
fact if you had a genius like Homer or
Dante living in the bantin
Empire well he would just become a
bureaucrat we would never know the
genius of Homer and Dante Homer and
Dante could only arise in tribal
societies okay
so that um yeah so does that make sense
to you guys okay and again this is just
an introduction to the conflict be
between these political systems Empire
versus republic bureaucracy versus um um
yeah right we will continue uh these
themes and these topics as we uh move on
throughout um Western history but I I
first want to introduce these ideas to
you it's really important that you
understand the difference between
paganism and Christianity because we'll
be referring uh to this conflict this
division later on in the semester as
well any questions about
this please feel free to argue
okay please feel free to ask questions
to argue um because when you do that it
helps me improve my own
thinking right any comments any
feedback okay so um I want I want to
give you some guys some time to think
about questions but before I do that I
want to I I want to look ahead over the
next couple weeks and tell you what
we'll be doing okay so we we did the
Roman Empire then we did the byzantines
so um as I explained to you the Roman
Empire
uh Western Roman Empire will collapse in
the year
476 when the last emperor uh ramus
Augustus is the the PO
okay but when he's the
poed people don't understand the Roman
Empire has come to an
end okay because um the people who are
still in charge think the Roman Empire
is continuing but now we have a long
period of Civil Wars throughout Europe
all right and these civil wars were
eventually lead to something called the
Holy Roman Empire which is something
like the uh which which is what
Charlamagne or the Franks will create
and this will lead interesting for us to
the to the rise of the
Vikings okay the Vikings are important
because they will go on and
basically influence British culture as
well as Russian culture all right so
Russia comes from the idea of the Rose
okay the Roose are basically just
Vikings
um over here we will begin we will see
the beginning of the abased califit
which is really the Golden Age of the um
Muslims but eventually they'll be
conquered by the
Mongols all right and the Congress of
the Mongols we eventually take us into
the Renaissance
Dante and this will Mark a be a new
beginning in world history okay so I I
just want to explain to you what we what
what we be doing we will definitely have
to do um the Holy Roman Empire that's
number one then this will lead us to the
Vikings number two then then we'll talk
about the abet caliphate number three
and then we'll talk about the Mongols
and then the Renaissance okay so this is
what we doing over next two to three
weeks right we'll be going very fast
throughout uh we'll be going very fast
uh the semester okay so just let you
know all right